Barack Obama returns to slam president
Trump and called for fundamental change
Joe Biden lays had a new radical program
and Democrats begin to realize that
Americans kind of want to reopen i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressive
vpmi savvy thin secure their internet
join them at expressvpn dot-com / Ben
before I begin I want to take a moment
to give a shout out to our advertising
partners they helped make this show
possible and you're patronizing our
advertising partners also helps make
this show possible that partnership is
really what makes the show glow so we
appreciate you we appreciate our
advertisers speaking of which you should
have uh cold-like several weeks ago it
turns out that gold is now at a
seven-year high you knew who knew you
should have buckled the people over at
Birch gold because they're versifying at
least a little bit into precious metals
is always the smart play it allows you
to hedge against inflation and
uncertainty in Black Swan events like
the one we are currently experiencing
well over thirty five million people
have now lost their jobs from the
economic fallout from coronavirus and
the lock downs it's probably gonna be
bigger than that by the time all of this
is over you should be diversified into a
form of currency that is not going to
cost you the moon when the government
gets a hold of it think of the position
you've been in now if you had actually
diversified a little bit when I told you
two months ago before May 31st with a
qualifying purchase Birch gold will give
you a free emergency kit this backpack
is absolutely loaded with everything you
can buy right now so safeguard your
savings with Birch gold they will help
safeguard your family like they did mine
there's no obligation you have nothing
to lose to take that first step
Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau don't wait until the
market drops more to protect your
hard-earned savings get your free
emergency kit today text Ben to 47 47 47
and diversify today again text Ben to 47
47 47 that's my name Ben to 47 47 47 and
work with my friends over at Birch gold
okay so let's begin with some very very
good news there actually is a fair bit
of good news this morning
good piece of good news number one the
testing trends all over the United
States seems to suggest that the summer
is actually having a fairly significant
impact on kovat 19 because as the lock
downs are ending state-by-state the
southern states seem not to be
experiencing a wild uptick in the number
of infections even though they are
gradually reopening now again they are
gradually reopening I've talked to
people in Florida I've talked to people
in Georgia I've talked to people in
Texas and despite the media reports that
everybody is willy-nilly going out in
the streets and making out with each
other that's not actually what's
happening a lot of stores have remain
closed because they can't actually abide
by some of the strict regulations most
people are still wearing masks most
socially distancing and even though
you're seeing pictures from places like
California in New York with lots of
people out there a lot of those pictures
are taking with particulars --is that
actually make it look as though people
are closer together than they actually
are it's it's a trick of photography and
it's sort of disturbing that people do
it but it is a reality yesterday my wife
and I took the kids out to a park
there's pretty much no one around people
who were around weren't socially
distancing we've been doing that for
weeks people sort of understand on a
general level what is smart and what is
not that doesn't mean everybody but that
does mean that more people then you
would suspect and that means that even
if there are some infections it's going
to be a lower level than prior to the
lockdown because people are engaging in
different behavior we're starting to see
those trends Scott Gottlieb former FDA
Commissioner put out a series of tweets
looking at some of those trends so in
tweet number one he put out from AEI a
graph showing the number of tests going
up across the country really really
rapidly so as of May 1st we were
experiencing something like 290 thousand
tests something like that run on May 1st
and on average probably the first the
the first week of May we were running
somewhere in the neighborhood probably
250,000 tests a day now we are running
on average closer to 400,000 tests a day
meanwhile the number of positives has
gone down steadily during that time
which means basically the number of
people who are positive with Cova 19 has
been stagnant and the number of tests is
going up because again the percentage is
just the numerator over the denominator
so if the numerator remains the same
meaning the number of people infected
and the denominator increases meaning
the number of people tested you are
going to see a decrease in the
positivity rate now there have been
people in the media who are lying to you
and it is line with statistics when they
say things like increasing numbers of
positives increasing number of absolute
positives that's if you test more people
you will get more positives that does
not mean contra to to some people's
again statistical illiteracy that does
not mean that the test is making people
positive it means that you're likely to
pick up the positives that are already
there when you test more often obviously
so two things can be true at once one
the number of absolute positives coming
back can be higher and two the rate of
positivity can be declining because you
are doing more absolute tests it's a
Scott Gottlieb also tweeted out the the
states where cases are increasing it's
showing slight increase in
taxes but again very difficult to tell
whether that increase in Texas is due to
like an absolute increase or whether
that is due to a or a percentage
increase or whether that is due to
additional testing in all likelihood
it's due to additional testing in
Louisiana very slight increase after
seeing a major peak earlier this year in
Virginia slight increase in Arkansas and
South Dakota a slight increase but again
testing is increasing in all of those
states it is also worthwhile noting only
about 60% of the United States actually
releases the results of these tests
meanwhile there are a solid probably 25
states where there has been no increase
in new cases right where there is no
actual spike in cases and that is states
ranging from Nevada to Connecticut to
Maryland to Florida in Florida was
supposed to be you know patient zero in
the outbreak Florida was supposed to be
where we were going to see this vast
increase in a second wave because evil
evil Ron de santis had allowed people go
to the beaches turns out none of that
was true it turns out that Florida is
much more of a success story than people
are making it out to be and one of the
things that you're noticing is that
again hotter States just are not
experiencing this in the same way the
colder states have experienced it
throughout the country at California did
not get hard hit Texas did not get
particularly hard hit Florida did not
get particularly hard hit major cities
you know Louisiana is fairly warm place
but Louisiana has has New Orleans New
Orleans got hit the rest of the state
really did not get hit all that hard
okay so Gottlieb concludes from this he
suggests that nationwide recent models
suggest doubling time is about 45 days
and the are not is around 110 so they
are not is the is the statistical
infection rate if you're above 1 that
means that it is growing if you are
below 1 that means that it is decreasing
because it's it's basically how many
people one person in facts so if they
are not is around 1.1.1 then that is a
slow epidemic right slow enough that you
are not gonna overwhelm the healthcare
system
Gottlieb says well it's still expanding
its doing so in a much slower place a
pace hopefully there will be a season of
seasonal effect in the summer that slows
it further ok so all of that is very
good news meanwhile there's another
piece of good news that's being kind of
positioned as a piece of bad news and
that is that as corona virus testing
expands not enough people are actually
testing so all the talk about test test
we need more tests more and more and
more tests according to the Washington
Post
people aren't taking the tests that are
out there by the way I've experienced
this myself my wife earlier this week
him down with a fairly high grade fever
it turns out that she just had an
infection okay but she went to we went
way I she got a Kovac 19:10 she's
nursing she got an infection from that
we actually went we got a kovat 19 tests
we were in line for like two seconds
seriously two seconds we we they have
stations set up all around Southern
California the available at the
availability of tests is extremely high
according to the Washington Post in fact
the availability of testing is so high
that not enough people are actually
accessing and testing so the Washington
Post reports four months into the u.s.
coronavirus outbreak test for the virus
finally are becoming widely available a
crucial step toward lifting stay at home
orders and safely returning to normal
life well wedding while many states no
longer report of crippling supply
shortages a new problem has emerged too
few people lining up to get tested okay
so on the one hand the suggestion is
that a lot of people should be getting
tested we're not getting tested on the
other hand what that really means it
listen right now in America if you have
corona virus symptoms high likelihood
you're gonna go get tested high
likelihood but that really means there
are a lot of asymptomatic people out
there or people who are actually not
sick with cor no virus at all a
Washington Post survey of governor's
offices and state health department's
found at least a dozen states where
testing capacity outstrips the supply of
patients many have scramble to make
testing more convenient especially for
vulnerable communities by setting up
pop-up sites and developing apps that
help assess symptoms find free test
sites and deliver quick results but the
numbers while rising are well short of
capacity and far short of targets set by
independent experts Utah for example is
conducting about 3,500 tests a day
that's a little more than a third of its
9,000 test maximum capacity health
officials have erected highway
billboards begging drivers to get tested
for kovat 19 why aren't more people
showing up well that's the
million-dollar question shed you talk
Health Department spokesman Tom who
dodged go it could be simply that people
don't want to be tested it could be that
people feel like they don't need to be
tested it could be that people are so
mildly symptomatic they're just not
concerned that having a positive lab
result would actually change their
course in any meaningful way see I think
it's probably the latter
well maybe it's just maybe it's just you
know
confirmation bias from the people I talk
to you in my crowd it's it's certainly
anecdotal but let's just put it this way
if anybody in my circle had coronavirus
symptoms they would immediately go get
tested I don't know how
people across the United States have the
symptoms and they're like you know what
screw it not getting tested today maybe
it's just that not that many people are
experiencing symptoms or at least severe
symptoms sufficient that they feel like
they need to go get tested
experts say several factors may be
preventing more people from seeking
tests including a lingering sense of
scarcity a lack of access in rural and
underserved communities concerns about
cost and skepticism about testing
operations ella stanford is a pediatric
surgeon in philadelphia she's providing
free testing and low-income and minority
communities she says we know there's a
lack of trust in the african-american
community with the medical profession
she has an effort which offers testing
in church parking lots they serviced
more than 3000 people in recent weeks
also there's lingering confusion about
who qualifies last month the CDC relaxed
its guidelines to offer tests of people
without symptoms or referred by local
health department's or clinicians some
states have relaxed their testing
criteria dramatically governor brian
Kemp has encouraged all Georgians even
if they're not experiencing symptoms to
schedule an appointment so by the way if
if George is actually encouraging people
to go out and get tested and today about
a larger number of people getting tested
you would expect to see a spike in
positives right Oklahoma governor Kevin
Stick and Republican urged residents
earlier this month to call 2-1-1 find a
location close to you even if you don't
have symptoms and you are just curious
ashish Jha who directs the Harvard
Global Health Institute said a lot of
states put in very very restrictive
testing policies because they didn't
have tests if you they're not waxed
those who the word is not getting out we
want to be at a point where everybody
who has mild symptoms is tested that's
critical that is still not happening in
a lot of places but again as we move
forward it seems like if you won't
listen if you wanted to get tested
before you basically had to fib if you
want to get tested you had to say that
you knew something CDC standards were so
ridiculous that was like do you know
somebody who's had corona virus it's
like well I don't know that person
wasn't tested right well okay so to get
the test you Feb and Peggy Noonan talked
about this in the Wall Street Journal
but now that is not the way that this is
working now basically if you say that
you have symptoms you can get tested
virtually across the country California
has sufficient lab capacity to conduct
nearly a hundred thousand tests today
they're averaging fewer than 40,000 in
Chicago a major chain of urgent care
clinics temporarily halted mobile
testing last week I ran out of test kits
as states trying to encourage people to
return to normal life ramp up testings
experts
worried that widespread shortages could
occur
but the federal government is moving to
fill that gap the federal government is
moving quickly to fill that gap bottom
line is this the if it does not seem
like there is on the grounds a man for
testing that is not appearing so much as
a national demand for testing because
there is this again slogan out there the
testing and tracing are the solution to
this thing when you are providing more
tests than people are actually taking
advantage of that is not a problem of
supply that is a problem of demand and
the federal government is doing its best
to fill that in but what that really
shows is that we are not experiencing
overwhelming of the health care system
we are not experiencing overwhelming
numbers of cases and this is driving a
sort of change in the rhetoric that you
are seeing from Democrats so for a while
there the rhetoric was we got to shut
down until we have vaccine oh by the way
another piece of good news
moderna is now announcing that they've
had positive interim phase one data for
their new mRNA vaccine they're saying
that their new tests on the vaccine are
successful and they are moving forward
so there are many vaccines apparently
that are now in preclinical result
testing and they've seen some very
positive results they're trying to
figure out exactly what the dosage
should be but the bottom line is that
this is very good news as Scott Gottlieb
says encouraging news today on moderna
vaccine technology will eventually let
us reduce the Cova threat and will claim
normal times early data shows it
generates robust immune reaction it's
dose dependent getting dose right is key
moderna is now testing a new 50
milligram dose we must stop my Krogh amp
microgram dose rather we must establish
regulatory measures for antibody titers
clinical measures of benefit to serve as
clear benchmarks of success for studies
right now FBI requires neutralizing
antibody titer of at least 1 to 164
convalescent serums owners is that the
level for a vaccine there's some
suggestion the vaccines could protect us
from bad symptoms of color but not
totally protect us from getting the
infection sort of like a flu shot okay
well I think that we would all go for
that right if this was reduced to the
danger of the flu I think we would all
be like okay done done okay and then
good news is that seems to be the
direction we are moving so all of this
is good news all this is good news is it
the summer seems to be slowing the
spread as dr. Marty Meharry of Johns
Hopkins told me last week it seems as
though the testing shortages are
actually not supremely material in most
major states at this point it seems like
it's really more a problem of people
being aware that they can get a test
then
people wanting to get a test and it is
that the tests are not available which
is good news and this is changing a lot
of the rhetoric politically surrounding
a reopening we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about how
you're staying home all day you've been
looking around your house you know this
place looks pretty good except it feels
kind of dingy why look at your window
coverings I know you never do that
look your window coverings you never
replace those when you got your place
did you can replace them at your
apartment you didn't replace them at
your house well blinds.com
can help you replace those ugly window
coverings and do it quickly and
inexpensively and beautifully really
they make great stuff not everybody has
the means to do a full renovation there
are small changes you can make to help
improve your home and this is where
blinds.com comes in they make it simple
to shop top-quality blinds shades and
interior shutters from home with easy
online ordering in free shipping window
treatments are a simple project you can
do that really benefit the look and feel
of your home experts say not getting
enough Sun can increase levels of stress
hormones in your body
considering light filtering window
treatments roller shades hell your
slates and more transform your home into
even more of a sanctuary if you're
nervous about doing it yourself you
don't have to be because blinds.com
really helps you through the process
free online design help plus they
guarantee the perfect fit so if you
screw it up and you miss measure they
will resend it to you anyway go to
blinds.com
see how you can reimagine the look of
your home today I've done it myself with
lines that come they make it super easy
rules and restrictions may apply
blinds.com
see how you can reimagine the look of
your home today go check out blinds.com
all righty so you can see that the that
the Democratic rhetoric around this
thing as I say is really changing fairly
radically so for example Andrew Cuomo on
testing so last week Andrew Cuomo's we
don't have enough testing the testing is
not there we just don't have enough
testing testing testing and it turns out
that Andrew Cuomo governor of New York
he did the same thing with testing he
did with ventilators which is he said he
needed a lot more than you needed right
he said I need a hundred thousand
ventilators turns out they didn't need a
fraction of that so over the course of
the last few weeks it's been Cuomo
saying we need testing testing many
tested we just need tons of tests
yesterday Cuomo announced that the New
York State drive-through Milwaukee and
locations are capable of testing 15,000
people a day and they are currently
testing 5,000 people a day in other
words there is a surplus per day of
10,000 tests okay that is not a testing
shortage so all the rips remember the
rip was on Trump he's not kidding the
ventilators then he got the ventilators
then it was they're not getting us the
tests then they got them the test seems
like the problem right now is that
kovat 19 is just a part of life right
that is the problem for now the problem
is not the testing the problem is not
the medical care cuz we have not swamped
the medical system the problem is that
we are all just going to have to assess
our own personal levels of risk and be
responsible and that's it that's all we
can do until the vaccine is developed
good news is it looks like a few months
until maybe there will be some sort of
workable vaccine that at least drives
down the symptoms or if there are punic
that drives down the symptoms sufficient
we can go back to our normal everyday
lives when I say normal everyday lives I
don't mean with social distancing with
masks I mean I think that we are
probably a few months away from going
back to like actual regular life I think
that we are gonna get back to the point
where people actually do go to ball
games we're gonna get back to the point
where people do shake hands with one
another I don't think handshakes are
dead forever by the way I think what
hopefully will still keep some things
like washing their hands a lot and not
touching our faces so much but I think
that as we develop therapeutics in a
vaccine that is the hope don't do it
prematurely but that is the hope in the
near future
and until then we mitigate risk and buy
ourselves time because the therapeutics
are coming down the pike now as I say
you know there there is the sort of
pessimistic vision of the future in
which there is no vaccine and there's no
therapeutic in which case you just want
to achieve herd immunity as fast as
possible which in the United States
would be pretty dangerous because there
are a lot of unhealthy people but I
don't think that's necessary I think
that if we're all responsible for a few
months we're going to get closer to
normal by September October November
certainly by the beginning of next year
then many people had thought including
me early on in this process and you're
starting to see Democrats adapt their
talk about this so here's Cuomo expand
explaining we actually have more testing
than we can use right now we have more
sites and more testing capacity than
we're using okay that's a good problem
but that is the next from hurdle to
hurdle right stone to stone yeah I see
it more like from hurdle to hurdle
than the track now we have more testing
capacity more sites than we're actually
using we have driving sites that can do
15,000 per day we're doing about 5,000
per day okay so again we're not we're
not actually short on the tests at this
point in new york state which is the
state hardest hit by this stuff
meanwhile over in Colorado Jared
Powell's who's a Democrat you came out
he said you know we're actually doing
well recounting our cup of 19 deaths we
think we overestimated how many deaths
there were which is pretty astonishing
remember when Trump said this he was
ripped up and down when any Republican
has suggested
that the classification of Cova deaths
has actually been too broad because it
it counted people who died with kovat as
opposed to people who died of kovetz
you're 82 years old
you have many pre-existing medical
conditions you get kovat but you
actually die of something else you'd
have a heart attack or something and you
were classified as a cove at 19 death or
you're classified as a cove at 19 death
when you die in your home and you're
just an excess death and we don't
actually know why you died policies like
you know what if we're actually gonna be
statistically accurate about this thing
then we need to measure people who died
of kovat 19 as opposed to people who
died with kovin 19 this guy's the
Democrats that means he's not getting
ripped up and down that's the way this
works in the media you can make exactly
the same argument if you are a Democrat
as if you're a Republican the Democrat
will be praised for the argument the
Republican will be ripped here's Jared
palace making an argument that many
people have been making on the
Republican side of the aisle for a while
these are deaths that should not be
politicized the CDC criteria include
anybody who has died with Cove in 19
what the people of Colorado and the
people of country did want to know is
how many people died of koban 19 in our
state about 900 have died from Kobe 19
on their death certificate or from the
attending physician about 1,100 have
died with it that was 200 in the middle
it might have been a contributing factor
but it wasn't deemed the sole factor or
the only factor in their death weird
because again if you mentioned this like
just a few weeks ago then the suggestion
is you were downplaying the virus again
Jared Powell's can reopen Colorado in
exactly the same ways Brian came to
reopen Georgia and he can say exactly
the same stuff is President Trump about
downgrading the number of deaths not a
shred of criticism from the media not
one Andrew Cuomo can completely blow it
in his state not a shred of criticism
from media that to does an 80% approval
rating and he was shoving old people
with Kovan 19 back into nursing homes
now Cuomo by the way is actually on the
defensive so yesterday he said we're not
gonna prosecute anyone for nursing home
that's come on guys that's not serious I
mean come on we're not gonna do anything
about that who is accountable for those
139 deaths how do we get justice for
those families who had 139 deaths what
is justice who can we prosecute for
those dentists nobody nobody
mother nature God where did this virus
come from people are going to die by
this virus that is the truth okay and
then he went on to say this is a direct
quote older people vulnerable people are
going to die from this virus this is
going to happen despite whatever you do
weird because there were those of us who
were saying this when it came to risk
mitigation there were those who were
saying this when it came to how do we
strategize about tranching populations
back into the workforce there were those
of us who were saying this and we
trended on Twitter for saying this
Andrew Cuomo says it everybody's like ah
well you know they easy Andrew Cuomo
hero of the people man
hero of the people so now we're allowed
to say the stuff that's true out loud
when it becomes clear that now we are on
the downtrend and when it becomes clear
that it's gonna cost Democrats if they
continue to keep every part of the
economy shut down for extended periods
of time despite the fact that the
evidence doesn't show that we should do
all of that Rahm Emanuel the former
chief of staff to Barack Obama he says
guys I think Democrats are kind of too
resistant about reopening we're gonna
need to talk re-opening now on the
Democratic side I'm messaging we look a
little too much too much about
resistance about reopening too much
about reluctance about reopening and we
should go to a message of rebuilding
America - if the president wants to talk
about reopening we want to talk about
rebuilding America in the relief let's
take the unemployed if you're unemployed
in the service sector
JCPenney some of these others those jobs
aren't coming back so we're gonna give
you a coupon go become a computer coder
in six months we'll pay for it you don't
have to pay a penny out of your pocket
learn to code is the Democrats a new
program but the main point of what Rahm
Emmanuel's saying is correct which is
the Democrats have been extremely
resistant to reopen and why because the
media calculus was such until the last
five minutes the media calculus was such
that if you said lockdown until every
life is safe my grandmother she means
everything to me then you were rewarded
and if you said guys we have to figure
out a way to reopen because the economy
is dying in 40 million people are out of
work and everybody is losing their life
savings and their life dreams then you
are a bad person but now that it appears
that we're on the down slope then and it
appears that Florida and Georgia and
things could reverse but Florida and
Georgia among many other states do not
appear that they're being overwhelmed in
terms of health care system and not
being close to overwhelmed in terms of
the health care system now the rhetoric
is starting to change and we're all
getting to where I suggested we were
going to be in the
place which is individual
decision-making about risk mitigation
Wow who could have suggested all of this
stuff weeks ago months ago oh right that
yeah I did
sorry not Sam right but I'm I was
totally right we'll get to that in just
we'll get to how right I was
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that this is a crazy job
market and you could use nothing better
than to find the best employee in this
market and to find the best employer in
this market market if you're now looking
for a job this is why you need zip
recruiters zip recruiters focus has not
changed they're still doing what they
have always done helping people find
work helping businesses find the right
people for their open roles if you're
looking for a job
zip recruiter is working with you to
find the right job faster they're
dedicated to helping you get hired from
caretaking to delivering food and goods
to building medical facilities supplying
protective equipment and so much more in
fact zip recruiters app will send you an
up-to-date job opening so you can be one
of the first to apply if you're actively
hiring zip recruiter will invite
candidates to apply to your most urgent
roles making it faster and easier to
reach the people you need by connecting
people who need jobs and companies that
need people zip recruiter is working
with all of us so we can keep moving
forward this is a very good thing in
this job market you need a service
that's going to connect the best
employees with the best employers if
your are a prospective employee you need
the job listing ASAP and if you're an
employer you need the best employees
ASAP zip recruit connects everybody zip
recruiters comm / work together that is
zip recruiter comm / work together go
check them out right now okay so as we
see people are engaging in risk
mitigation or risk taking as they as
they see fit in New York people were
going back out to bars and beaches
according to the New York Post locked
down we're in New Yorkers ditching the
distancing to get social instead this
weekend transforming parts of the Big
Apple into Rock is a late season Mardi
Gras yet the city's Cove it'd be jams
attitude was nothing compared with the
scene in Belmar New Jersey a beach
popular of Staten Islanders and Brooklyn
Heights huge crowds waited shoulder to
shoulder on the boardwalk for their turn
to buy beach badges Hawaiian for Beach
badges is like for non socially distance
blacks lungs weed insured Seidler who
described the boardwalk as obscenely
packed now I don't know the New Jersey
or I don't know the beach badges thing
is that something they're doing just cuz
of covered in 19 or is that's something
that you actually have to do in New
Jersey I just actually don't know the
answer to that if you actually if the
government has now restricted it so you
have to buy a beach badge so it's not to
overcrowd the beach so you just end up
with a crowded line then that's what you
call policy stupidity
at the highest level outside bars on the
Upper East Side the Upper West Side the
East and West Village isn't in
Greenpoint Brooklyn the post found booze
hounds arriving for the takeout
cocktails and then staying and staying
to sip drinks on packed sidewalks and
soak up the lively scenes they're gonna
drink with the mast on said one reveler
hairdresser Akeem Kelley his mast dangle
below his chin as he stood outside the
Upper East Side's popular Dorian's Red
Hand bar where crowds exceeding three
dozen nearly all unmasked were found in
the early evenings of Friday and
Saturday they don't care about a sedan
trend 72 of Manhattan on Saturday she
sat on a bench at the west end of the
Brooklyn Bridge as a steady stream of
masks free sightseers and bicyclists
passed her by and she mused what
happened to all of us protecting
everybody else okay I'll tell you what
happened is that a bunch of young people
said I don't care if I get this right
that's actually what's going on right
now and that may not be best policy and
in fact if you see an elderly person
anywhere in your near vicinity you're
gonna want to throw up that mask but can
we stop pretending that a bunch of 20
year olds hanging out at the bar it's
the same thing as a bunch of people at a
nursing home hanging out together it is
not okay now again I think that for
purposes of slowing the spread I here's
my rule my personal rule has been that
when I am out and about if I'm 6 feet
away from everybody else and outdoors I
don't wear a mask but when I'm outdoors
my kids I don't wear a mask when I go
into a restaurant to pick up food when I
go over to a garden supply store where
I'm in close proximity with people I put
on the masks and I think that's a fairly
good rule and that's a good rule mainly
because you know I just don't know who's
vulnerable and who is not vulnerable
however if you're talking about like a
bar scene and everybody there is 20 I
got to say that the risk factor is in
terms of people dying of kovat are not
particularly high especially if
everybody again socially distances from
the most vulnerable and that's a
decision that you are going to have to
make yourself what is not a smart
decision and not a good decision is if
you're not wearing the mask and you are
near somebody who you know is vulnerable
that would be a stupid decision but
again I think that young stupid people
tend to do young stupid things that does
not mean that you're gonna get people to
stop doing young stupid things that
didn't even stop during the covert
outbreak so here's what's actually
happening most people who are
risk-averse are being risk-averse most
people who are being risk seeking are
being risk seeking and most people are
actually being fairly smart about this
the media are gonna pick out these
instances of people who are being dumb
and they're gonna highlight those so
that they can claim that the government
needs to be deeply involved in
regulating individual behavior but the
reality is that if you got tens of
millions of people who are engaging an
individual decision making and
that's just how it's going to be that's
just the reality of life there's a good
article today in the San Jose Mercury
News News talking about risk assessment
says as an infectious disease expert dr.
George Rutherford knows all about the
horrors of Cova 19 there's one risk the
UC San Francisco professor wearing a
mask is willing to take hugging his
two-year-old granddaughter for two
months we've been diligent about staying
home but as Bay Area residents start to
venture out with parts of the state
gradually loosening lockdown
restrictions how do we navigate this new
landscape of peril and promise we can't
stay isolated and fearful forever the
new normal looks like this social lives
carefully built around risk reduction
rather than the strict and absolute
safety of isolated sheltering Stanford
University communications professor Jeff
Hancock he says we need to balance our
needs with what we know about the corona
virus he said abstinence doesn't work
plans that are practical and recognized
basic human needs will be more
successful than plans that don't so we
need a vacation in Costa Rica with lots
of friends know do we need intimate and
social moments yes
risk isn't binary experts agreed
all-or-nothing approaches have bad
consequences where have you been for the
last several months serious like if you
mentioned this before that risk
mitigation was going to be the answer
you were the bad guy but now apparently
we're all allowed to talk risk
mitigation I wonder what change I wonder
what changed maybe it was that a bunch
of Republican states started to reopen
didn't see massive spikes and people
around the country they're like oh look
at that
oh look at that okay well what all of
this has led to is a change in in sort
of democratic messaging for 2020 so as I
say they started to talk with a opening
that's the thing that has happened but
they also have to come up with a new
message because let's say that people
start reopening and people are generally
responsible and the economy starts to
reopen people start getting hired back
slowly but surely we come up with some
therapeutics by the time we get to fall
schools are open and we are basically
let's say best-case scenario we're back
to 80% of normal by November and the
economy is moving back up again and no
one's gonna blame Trump for the
coronavirus it's just not going to
happen
you can't blame Trump for a for a
worldwide pandemic that knocked out
places like Italy and knocked out places
like UK the United States ranges
middle-of-the-pack when it comes to
number of deaths per million and when
you take out New York City we range near
the bottom okay so really it was a New
York failure and everybody else did kind
of okay aside from some of the major
cities like New Orleans in Chicago okay
because the United States is a fairly
diffuse place in terms of popular
except for those major population center
specifically in New York City okay so
the Democrats have to come up with a new
message
and they have their new message which
they will get all the support in the
world from the media from if for is they
need to remake the system utterly and
completely so Brock Obama wheeled out
this new message today it's the same as
their old message right every every
crisis is an opportunity every bad
situation is just an indicator that we
need to remake the system completely
sober rock Obama gave a speech over the
weekend to people who are graduating
from college and was widely praised by
the media for doing so because Obama
could fart in the media would praise him
for it his farts smell like roses
according to the members of CNN's
editorial board so Barack Obama gave the
speech and his speech included I don't
know why in the middle of a graduation
he would do this but apparently it's a
very unifying thing it's very unifying
to say that the leadership of the
country sucks when you're the
ex-president man has Jimmy Carter
syndrome it is kind of amazing by the
way you notice how Republican presidents
I don't think Trump will do this but
every other Republican president
basically went away after their
President Reagan stopped talking HW
didn't talk w didn't talk it was like
okay we're done now my job is over not
Barack Obama right Obama is out there
and he is and he is jabbering up a storm
because he has to defend his legacy
against President Trump he thinks we'll
get to Barack Obama's addressed you
graduates in just one second first right
now not a great time to go to the post
office first of all why would you go to
the post office anyway you can just do
everything online and can save a lot of
money while doing it but right now
waiting in line holding packages with a
bunch of people who are also holding
packages in line in a closed area
they're not probably the best move you
can avoid it this is why you need stamps
calm with stamps calm you can print
postage on demand then skip the lines
and the crowds at the post office plus
you can actually save some money with
discounts you can't even get at the post
office
as if that wasn't enough stamps calm
also offers UPS services with discounts
up to 62% and no UPS residential
surcharges here is daily where we've
been using stamps calm since 2017 we're
not wasting our time any more stamps
calm brings all the services of the US
Postal Service direct to your computer
in the safety and comfort of your own
home office or anywhere else you are
hunkering down right now whether you're
a small business sending invoices or an
online seller shipping out products or
you're just working from home and you
need to mail some stuff stamps.com can
handle it all with ease simply use your
computer to print official US postage
24/7 for any letter any package any
class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready just leave it for your
mail carrier schedule a free package
pickup or drop it in a mailbox no human
contact required it is indeed that
simple stamps that calm great stuff like
i said with stamps icon you get a great
discounts as well five cents off every
first-class stamp up to 62 percent off
shipping rights stamps calm is a
no-brainer especially right now this of
your time it'll save you money right now
my listeners get a special offer it
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and digital scale no long-term
commitment just go to stamps comm click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage type in Shapiro data stamps
comm enter Shapiro stamps.com all ready
in just a second I'm gonna get to Barack
Obama and the new Democratic agenda but
it was Trump is blowing this thing now
turns out from didn't blow the thing
that bad it turns out that Trump is not
a great communicator as we all knew and
he does dumb things on Twitter and also
the ventilators were there and also the
testing is being provided and also
states are basically taking the lead and
also the people who are defending trying
to look terrible today
okay so Democrats have to come up with a
new plan Obama laid it out yesterday
we'll get to that momentarily first the
double tumbler is back but it is only
available for our most exclusive
membership tier I'm talking about
all-access baby the all-access
membership here is our premier level of
membership all access members get to
participate in all access live our
brand-new interactive programming
featuring one of us daily where our host
as we hang out with you each night all
access members also get to join us for
real time at Q&A discussions available
on both the website and the daily wear
app all access membership now includes
two of the irreplaceable leftist ears
tumblers to count them to the tumblers
are literally overflowing with tears at
the thought of this offer they're
multiplying like rabbits around here
right behind me they're like 83 of them
it's like the it's like the the weird
creatures from Star Trek whose name
escapes me the triples the truffles in
any case all access members also get our
benefits of our our other membership
tiers including an ADD free website
experience access 12 of our live
broadcasts in the show library access to
the shows mailbags the full three hours
of the ben shapiro shot along with
dedicated editorials from moi so head on
over to daily wire calm slash subscribe
join all access get 15% off of coupon
code Shapiro right now that is Daily
wire.com slash subscribe we'll see you
there you are listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
leave it to producer Nick to inform me
that those are triples that's correct
that the trouble with tribbles
okay so President Obama gives this the
speech to graduates and he lays out the
democratic program program number one
he's gonna yell at Trump out heard from
sucks program number two this kovin 19
oh the America needs fundamental change
weird because I thought that when he
came on to the scene we got the
fundamental change right it turns out
there's never change fundamental enough
for the left because in the left-wing
worldview any inequality is an inequity
meaning anything that is unequal in life
is not about the fact that people are
not actually equal in all of their
capacities and all of their skill sets I
am short I'm not going to be playing in
the NBA I have no jump shot I can't dunk
right but apparently that's an inequity
that's some sort of unfairness so
everything in America is about
unfairness it is not about the fact that
any statistical division you draw in
American society is going to include
inequality so if that is your viewpoint
then the only indicator that you have
reached fairness is when everybody ends
up with exactly the same results
basically no matter what they do you
take the decision-making out of the
process so that means that it is
perpetual revolution on the left means
doesn't matter if Obama fundamentally
transformed America matter not
fundamental enough it's never
fundamental enough we never reached that
utopia okay so Barack Obama said two
things one he ripped into Trump two he
suggested that Kobe 19 shows systemic
racism okay it doesn't matter
that we are expending extraordinary
resources for all Americans then get the
treatment that they need no this is
really about how America has a legacy
somehow the death rates from Kovan 19
our evidence of Jim Crow and slavery
which again I guess in a certain sense
is true but only in the sense that all
history is contingent meaning that all
history leads to other things happening
in the future if Adam and Eve hadn't
eaten from the apple tree then
presumably fewer people would be dying
of copán 19 right now and that that's
not a supremely helpful analysis of the
current situation when it comes to
policy on the ground here's Barack Obama
making the fundamental case for
transformation of American society which
is now being picked up by Joe Biden as
well than anything this pandemic is
fully finally torn back the curtain on
the idea that so many of the folks in
charge know what they're doing a lot of
them aren't even pretending to be in
charge if the world is going to get
better it's going to be up to
you with everything suddenly feeling
like it's up for grabs this is your time
to seize the initiative okay weird so so
you're gonna seize the innit that's
that's very odd because what I've been
told by people like Obama is that if he
were in charge then we could all just
listen to him but since Trump is in
charge you should use your own
individual judgment as opposed to me
where I say like I don't care who's in
charge you should use your individual
judgment you notice how this works when
a Democrat is in charge pay attention to
Authority when a Democrat is not in
charge it's up to you America okay what
okay then Obama gets to his real point
and his real point is that America is
fundamentally unequal and evil and
terrible and 16:19 project is right
right this is the message that Obama's
pushing here a disease like this just
spotlights the underlying inequalities
and extra burdens that black communities
have historically had to deal with in
this country we see it in the
disproportionate impact of kovat 19 on
our communities just as we see it when a
black man goes for a jog and some folks
feel like they can stop and question and
shoot him if he doesn't submit to their
questioning injustice like this isn't
new okay that's insane
okay what he's saying right now is
totally insane the reason that is
totally insane is first of all if you're
going to differentiate how Kobe 19 is
affecting populations
you'd have to first figure out a couple
of things one people who are obese and
have diabetes and have pre-existing
conditions this is more prevalent in
minority communities than it is in the
white community that's just a
statistical truth okay that has nothing
to do with race that has everything to
do with eating habits and the kind of
food people have access to and all of
that kind of stuff - are people actually
socially distancing do people live in
intergenerational households right a lot
of people who are white tend not to live
as much with Grandma a lot of people in
the minority communities they hadnít in
Hispanic communities for example have
lots of cross generational pollination
this is also true in the black community
that's not a bad thing it's not a rip I
think it's actually quite a good thing
in many ways but it does mean that you
are more susceptible to passing on Kove
at 19 - other people might you have to
take all of these into account that does
not mean that some inequity has taken
place you'd have to actually filter out
all of the different decision-making
variables but according to Obama if
black people are hit harder by kovat 19
statistically that means that America is
racist and this can
be attributed to Jim Crow he doesn't
have to bother to do the statistical
analysis and figure out how much of this
is due to inequity you can just
immediately cite inequality and he can
then connect it to another case where it
is not clear that the driving factor was
racism the outcome of our berry case
right so the automata bearing case is an
awful awful case we talked about this at
length the day after this broke in the
news like big we talked about the fact
that I think that those guys should be
prosecuted that you don't have the
ability to chase down somebody and
basically hold them at gunpoint for a
non crime that is not something you can
do however we do not have evidence at
this point that the that the incident
was driven by race primarily as opposed
to being driven by vigilantism by the
people who are actually doing this thing
and driven by an insider corrupted deal
basically between the DA in that area
and the ex-cop who committed the
shooting along with his son right so
what what so this is why Obama's
demagoguery is really so dangerous when
Trump is demagoguing he just says
something dumb are you something
something ridiculous like he'll just say
like Joe Scarborough is off killing
interns or something right he'll just
say something or it can immediately go I
gotta come on Obama tries to create a
superstructure of extraordinarily
radical claims on top of very thin reads
and then wait for the media to bolster
him so he will say things like llamado
Barrett so look what he did in that clip
is pretty incredible
he said the omelet our Barry shooting is
about racism again we don't know that
it's about racism because we don't know
the background of the guys who committed
the shooting do they have all sorts of
racist texts did they've raised his
background was this done specifically
because they saw a black guy or is
because somebody in their neighborhood
said somebody's burglarizing a house and
they were like okay well whatever man
I'm a vigilante and we've had this
before and I'm by the way still criminal
still bad they should still go to jail
but we don't know the answer to that yet
so he takes a case where not all of the
facts are known he immediately
attributes it to deep-seated American
racism then he connects that to another
issue where it is not clear that racism
is the deciding game or is the
suggestion that our medical
professionals are racist is the
suggestion that our federal and state
governments all across the nation that
the New York government bill de blasio
has seen wildly disproportionate cases
of black people dying as opposed to
white people is Bill de Blasio and the
city government of New York racist and
Bill de valsa was like a full-blown
communist so you're gonna have to
explain that hey but
hasn't bothered to explain it the entire
program is about again America has
inequalities therefore America is bad
and therefore America needs to be
fundamentally transformed and this is
where Obama and burning wrongs act with
the same page Obama is just more subtle
about how he goes about this right
by a burning will just say America is
terrible America's a terrible place
filled with capitalism and brutality and
viciousness and we need to transform it
into a socialist utopia and so but
Bernie Obama is soft Bernie he just
let's get there gradually bernie is hard
Bernie Bernie is like giving me pooping
on communism Obama Obama still says that
he likes the free market maybe he does
you know I in a very limited fashion
heavily regulated fashion the same way
Elizabeth Warren likes the free market
as an ox that you can sort of chain up
to the plow of them of the American
economy and then direct it how you want
even if it ends up killing the ox but
Bernie says this more clearly so burning
over the weekend he says we need to
fundamentally rethink how society works
now remember everybody who is saying
this stuff that they were already saying
before Cove in nineteen if this is not
challenged any of your preconceptions
about when government should step in and
when government should not it's because
you're not actually following the facts
you are just reinforcing exactly what
you thought before as I've said before
reinforcing their priors reinforcing our
prior beliefs that is burning it doesn't
matter what the antecedent is in an
if-then statement all that matters is
the conclusion it doesn't matter what
the if is the then is we should be
socialist so could be if the sky is blue
we should be socialist if there's kovin
19 we should be socialist here's Bernie
yesterday explaining we need fundamental
change if there is any silver lining in
the midst of this terrible terrible an
unprecedented moment in American history
in terms of the economy in terms of the
pandemic it is that maybe we sought
rethinking some fundamental tenets about
the way our government in society works
and we should ask ourselves among other
things is health care a human right that
all of us deserve because we're human
beings or is it simply a healthcare
benefit that somehow we lose when we
lose our jobs
so Biden is picking up this torch so
Biden has been looking for some sort of
brazen that for his campaign his
campaign doesn't exist for anything
there's a campaign about nothing
it's the Seinfeld of campaigns okay he
sits in a basement and then he does
nothing and then he hopes to be
president now as I've said before that
was actually his
feature his best feature was the return
to normalcy campaign he's actually
making a very large strategic error here
so because it turns out that maybe we'll
get through this it turns out that we're
moving back toward normalcy it turns out
that our medical system withstood it and
the federal government did not in fact
do a terrible job and it turns out many
state governors who are Democrats like
Andrew Cuomo did an awful job maybe JB
Pritzker in Illinois didn't do a
fantastic job Gretchen Whitmer and
Michigan didn't do a fantastic job as
that turns out to be the case Biden is
now shifting his message and he's
looking for a positive reason to be
President now this is directly counter
to why he was nominated the reason he
was nominated is because people didn't
want Bernie the reason he was nominated
is because he was campaigning on the
warren g harding 1920 returned to
normalcy routine his entire campaign was
going to be about basically return to
status quo return to a time that was not
too crazy returned to a time where
everything was sort of more even even
keel
no one is voting for Joe Biden cuz they
want fundamental change people aren't
gonna vote for Joe Biden cuz they don't
want Trump that was the initial theory
of the Biden come in and it was strong
enough to win him the nomination over a
fundamental change candidate like Bernie
Sanders
well now Biden is going for Bernie
according to the New York Times more
than 36 million Americans are suddenly
unemployed Congress is allocated 2.2
trillion dollars in aid with more likely
to be on the way as a fight looms over
government debt millions more people are
losing their health insurance and
struggling to take care of their
children and aging relatives nearly
90,000 are dead in a continuing public
health catastrophe this was not the
scenario Joe Biden anticipated
confronting when he competed for the
Democratic nomination or on a
conventional left-of-centre platform now
with mr. Biden leading President Trump
in the poll the former VP and other
Democratic leaders are racing to
assemble a new governing agenda that
meets extraordinary times and they agree
it must be far bolder than anything the
party establishment has embraced before
this is such a miss Reid it is such a
dramatic miss Reid the best case that
you can make to moderates is you know
we're gonna get back 3.5% unemployment
you know we're gonna get back back to
normal you know what we're gonna get
back all the good stuff that was
happening just before this but Biden is
better at doing that than Trump because
Trump is is volatile and he says crazy
things on Twitter and he annoys you and
he says dumb crap right that was the
heart of the Biden campaign that's why
it was like elect his dead man as
opposed to electing Elizabeth Warren a
fundamental change candidate or electing
Bernie Sanders a fundamental change
candidate now Biden is saying
well I guess you know in light of this
disaster I'm gonna go full full-bore
radical now that actually opens the door
to Trump it's kind of shocking a truth
truth like this is political malpractice
on an incredible level Biden is not a
fundamental change candidate and if he
nominates a VP who is a fundamental
change candidate Kamala Harris if he
nominates a VP who's fundamental Stacey
Abrams then the the attack by the Trump
campaign is not going to be on Joe Biden
is old and incompetent and senile the
campaign is gonna be about would you
like back to three point five percent
unemployment we had just before this
with a functioning economy or do you
want Joe Biden spending trillions of
dollars on programs he didn't like in
the first place like universal health
care Medicare for all that involves
everybody losing the private health care
are you really interested in Joe Biden
just wiping away every last student loan
after you paid your student loans and
then thrusting that on the back of the
taxpayers but Joe but it's incredible
this is the greatest time for return to
normalcy campaign because guess what
everybody is aching for in their bones a
return to normalcy right that's what you
want it's what I want is what everybody
wants and Trump is trying to say okay
I'm gonna get back there but Biden could
easily say look Donald Trump is not I'm
old enough to remember when the slogan
against Trump was this is not normal
right this is not normal and if we don't
accept Trump is normal then we came back
to the old normal of kind of half
corrupt politicians like Joe Biden who's
been a lifelong Politico and sure he's
like boring and sure he's not all that
bright but you know at least you knew
what was coming in the morning and that
was the campaign for Joe Biden and now
he's shifting it according to the New
York Times mr. Biden's campaign has been
rapidly expanding its policy drafting
apparatus with the former VP promising
on Monday to detail plans for the right
kind of economic recovery
he's already effectively shed his
primary season theme of restoring
political normalcy to the country
replacing it with promises of sweeping
economic change he was running to
roughly counter to the basic political
calculus it says you run to the left
during the primaries and you run to the
center during the general he ran to the
center during the primaries and now he's
running to the left during the general
how does that making any sense at all he
is now opening the door like listen as a
Republican I'm happy if you want Trump
reelected you should be happy because it
does allow you to make the argument the
very proper argument that Joe Biden is
gonna radically shift the country on the
back of the pandemic on Wednesday Biden
signaled anew he was willing to reopen
his policy platforming announcing
policy Task Forces covering issues
including healthcare climate and
immigration as well as the economy that
combined his core supporters with
left-wing allies of senator Bernie
Sanders his vanquished primary opponent
so now he's gonna just eat alive the
Bernie Sanders program honest to god if
Trump does not go after him for the
radicalism its political malpractice
it's it's amazing it's amazing that he's
doing this it's so politically
incompetent on every insane level it's
sort of like when Mitt Romney decided
who's gonna campaign on the basis of
being severely conservative right what
he was really campaigning on being not
Obama and then Obama somehow made it
into a referendum on Romney well now
Trump can make this into a referendum on
Biden if Biden starts proposing radical
crap but that's what they're doing
they're talking about pumping trillions
more into the economy enacting
infrastructure and climate legislation
far larger than previously envisioned
passing a raft of aggressive worker
protection laws expanding government
backs health insurance creating enormous
new investments in public health jobs
healthcare facilities childcare programs
banning stock buybacks compelling big
corporations to share more of their
profits with workers a fundamental
remaking of the American economy you
think anyone was on board with this
that's why Biden was nominated cuz no
one was on board with this and he's
doing it anyway he's doing it anyway
it's an amazing amazing thing I mean
talk about seizing defeat from the jaws
of victory right now so this should be
the campaign for Trump the campaign for
Trump should be very easy Joe Biden
proclaimed that he is going to be back
to normalcy
this ain't normalcy and he's openly
saying he doesn't want normalcy pretty
incredible incredible stuff okay time
for some things that I hate so let's
talk about the media the media are just
absolutely egregious egregious I mean
they will they will cover any Democratic
narrative in the way the Democrats would
like it's truly impressive
so let's let's take for example Stacey
Abrams Stacey Abrams is a nonentity she
lost by 50,000 votes in the state of
Georgia 50,000 to Brian Kemp hey that is
not a close election that is a not close
election she is still being heralded as
the next big thing so much so that the
Washington Post magazine printed an
entire piece called the power of Stacey
Abrams despite losing the Georgia
governor's race in 2018 she has moved
quickly to political prominence
she'd be the vice presidential pick for
Democrats they would be insane to do
this but maybe Biden's gonna do that
maybe that's his job maybe maybe he
thinks that if he campaigns radical and
it's gonna redound to his benefit
because what you need is senility and
radicalism on the ticket makes perfect
sense how ridiculous is the Washington
Post piece about Stacey Abrams they
included a picture that looks as though
she's being backlit for a Broadway show
she's like there's fog emerging from
behind her as she wears a white seed
through cape and she's entirely in
silhouette I mean what in the world is
going she looks like a magician from Las
Vegas like slap a top hat and a cane in
her hand and she's gonna make a tiger
appear or something
it's absurdity she's gonna start singing
theme songs from wicked hey the bizarro
world bizarre this is what the
Washington Post portrays her ad in the
top picture by the way from the
Washington Post of her is a picture of
her sitting you know with a shiny table
right in front of her and the pictures
of her holding up to her and I what
looks like a giant monocle of an
American flag and every picture is like
this I mean this picture is particularly
ridiculous I've never seen a profile
picture like this then there's a giant
picture in the profile of a mural of her
of a mural of her in Atlanta on the side
of a building they're giving her like
full Che Guevara treatment here there's
a picture of her holding up a mirror of
herself so you can see I mean like every
photo is a romantic part now the media
have never taken a good picture of
Donald Trump ever hey every picture of
Donald Trump is him giving the smug grin
or he looks a little bit orange or
something but Stacey Abrams I think
posed her in front of fog in front of
fog and you have to listen to how this
piece is written this is they actually
have like a full paragraph describing
how you walk onto a stage not kidding
this is from the Washington Post piece
you ready pandemonium ensues as she
walks to the far left of the stage like
a runway supermodel stops on a dime
poses tilts her head slightly and smiles
camera flashes explode she next pivots
and walked slowly to the center of the
stage freezes there and repeats the pose
again the flashes explode Abrams is
summoning her inner actress and she's
both enjoying the moment and getting
through it to get to the conversation
she then pivots and walks to the far
right of the stage same you wonder
whether she has done this before because
it is not necessarily what one would
expect from a 46 year old politician
nearly elected the first black female
governor in US history she lost by fewer
than two percentage points in the 2018
Georgia race riddled with allegations of
voter suppression before that she was a
state legislator who had served as a
leader in the Georgia General Assembly
for a decade now her name is on
political pundits short list of
potential running mates for Joe Biden
she also happens to predicted she'll be
elected president by 2040 Wow she says
it I guess we have take it seriously
the losing gubernatorial candidate and
Georgia predicts that and she lost by
the way in a horrible year for
Republicans she predicts she's gonna be
president by 21 I take that at face
value I take that at face value I think
my daughter is gonna be elected
president of the United States by 2060 I
guess you have to take that SuperDuper
seriously now just as quickly Abrams
leaves the runway and returns to
politics a balloon of silence in the
meeting room is punctured time and again
by Amen and preach and you go girl hey
this is your media this is your pathetic
stupid terrible media and they are awful
awful in every possible way and this has
even infused people who I generally like
in the media
okay so you've heard me on the show
praise Jake Tapper before like I think
Jake is a very good journalist I also
think that Jake's coverage of the Trump
administration can be exceedingly biased
okay so let me give you an example so
today yesterday Jake Tapper was on with
Alice a czar and he suggested that they
were talking about coronavirus and the
Trump administration response and Jake
suggests that we were hit much harder
than other countries this is not true it
is not true by population we were not
hit harder than other countries in terms
of deaths per million the United States
ranks somewhere in the middle of Europe
and if you rank US without New York City
we rank near the bottom of Europe you
can't take the number of cases in the
United States or a number of deaths in
the United States and compared to Italy
which has one-sixth our population you
can compare us to the rest of Europe if
you take US compared to Europe we're
doing better than Europe overall if it
here is Jake not getting this right this
is just not getting it right the United
States has less than 5% of the world's
population but the United States has
also almost 30% of the world's
officially reported coronavirus deaths
you said back in January that quote the
risk is low our job is to work to keep
it that way
so did the US government fail why is
this virus hitting our country so much
harder than it's hitting other countries
so first just in term
of the actual case counts we are testing
more than other countries or than other
major countries and so we're seeing a
tremendous number of cases again it is
not correct to suggest that the United
States has hit harder than this than
other countries Europe has been hit with
162 thousand deaths the United States
has been hit with approximately 90
thousand that doesn't mean everything
was handled great here it wasn't it was
mostly not handled great by governors
for the first line of defense against
this sort of stuff not shoving people
back into nursing homes with kovat 19
but this is just not like and then you
see Chuck Todd right Chuck Todd doing
the same routine Trump is exploiting the
virus to pull us apart really is Trump
doing that or is it the media suggesting
from the very GetGo that President Trump
was blowing this thing suggesting that
he was withholding ventilators on the
base of personal protections suggesting
that Andrew Cuomo is a hero and Rhonda
Santos is a villain I'm very tired of
the media who have been engaged in
exactly the same sort of political
polarization as Trump suddenly
discovering that Trump is polarizing
like this this does not excuse Trump for
being polarizing during a time we need
unity but the media have been just as
polarizing and in many cases more
polarizing by deliberately miss covering
the stats again when you say that the
United States has seen more cases of
coronavirus we are testing more than any
other nation that doesn't mean that the
tests generate the positives as I said
before it does mean that unless you test
for flu you don't know whether people
have flu unless you are testing for a
heart attack you don't know there
somebody had a heart attack or some
other cause there was Chuck Todd blowing
it yesterday too
before the corona virus hit political
division was our pre-existing condition
and all this makes it easy to forget how
much most of us are actually pulling in
one direction to get us through the
worst health and now economic crisis in
a century so maybe this is a good moment
to remind ourselves of all those acts of
kindness selflessness and heroism that
do pull us together even as protestors
partisans and some high-profile
politicians exploit the situation to try
to what's apart okay again this is just
like have been watching the media
coverage the media coverage has all been
about a narrative of good and evil and
now it's shifted in real time as it
turns out that we can start moving
toward reopening it's just incredible
meanwhile the same media who say that
that only trump is polarizing that trump
is very bad they've jumped on people
talking about quote-unquote Obama gate
as a conspiracy hoax now I'm just gonna
point out that when Donald Trump
suggested that the media coverage of
Corona buyer
was a hoax that they were saying the
federal government wasn't doing anything
and that was a hoax the media
immediately suggested that what Trump
meant by that is that coronavirus itself
was a hoax that was a hoax that wasn't
true that was a for Pinocchio claim it
was repeated endlessly by members of the
media repeated endlessly by the
Democratic Party it is not a conspiracy
hoax to point out that half of the Obama
administration was involved in unmasking
Michael Flynn and that it was a pretty
good shot that if you spend half your
time following around Michael Flynn and
you have half the administration with
access to Michael Flynn's name and then
it leaks to the media that somebody
somewhere did something wrong that is
not a hoax when it turns out that the
evidence supporting the idea of a Trump
Russia collusion allegation was
extraordinarily skimpy like really
skimpy the first half of the Imola
report which is all about Trump Russia
collusion is extraordinarily thin like
really thin thin like Homer Simpson's
hair thin unbelievably thin it's the
second half when it comes to obstruction
where you start getting into Trump
acting like a crazy person but the first
half that Trump Russia collusion stuff
turned out to be a big nothing burger a
giant burger of nothing hey and when you
say it looks like they bent the rules on
that FISA warrant for Carter page which
they did which a judge which the
Inspector General found when you find
that Andrew McCabe lied to the media
I mean lied to the FBI Ryan didn't get
prosecuted when it turns out that James
Comey was keeping open an investigation
into Michael Flynn even after the FBI
knew that there was no actual material
reason for the investigation to be open
against Michael Flynn you start to think
okay well let's take best-case scenario
these people are firmly convinced that
Trump Russian collusion happened and
they're willing to bend any and every
rule in order to prove that it happened
and carried on for two three years and
the media were complicit in that but
then like Jake yesterday he goes after
Senator Ron Johnson he says this is all
conspiracy hoax this Obama gate thing
okay it is not a conspiracy hoax to
point out that people were routinely
bending rules that they were being over
broad about their application of
unmasking to many many people and that
would probably lead to the possibility
of leaks to the media which indeed
happened hey that's not a concern I'm
not claiming that it was a top down
conspiracy to get Michael Flynn I'm not
claiming that it was a top down
conspiracy to leak his name to the media
I'm not claiming any of those things
I'm just claiming that a bunch of people
who are thinking in the same direction
namely that Trump Russia collusion
definitely happened we have to stop
these guys before it's too late
that those people bent the rules in
extraordinary ways that if this had
happened Trump to Obama and not Obama to
Trump we would be talking about
impeachment on that basis alone probably
and that is just a reality here's here's
Jake Tapper though suggesting to Ron
Johnson that all of the Obama gates
discussion all Michael Flynn discussions
a conspiracy hoax you have not made the
allegation that the Trump administration
is making which is that President Obama
committed crimes you haven't said
anything along those lines but your work
you're requesting of this information of
the National the Director of National
Intelligence Rick for now and again I'm
I'm Pro transparency true or at least at
all but your work is being cited as an
exam as evidence for this crackpot
conspiracy theory does that bother you
again you keep calling a crack about
conspiracy theory I'm just trying to
find out what happened again I don't
know where people keep getting this idea
that anyone who is serious is claiming
that Barack Obama was like I want you to
go falsely get Michael Flynn
like that's not what anybody is really
claiming here they're claiming that
Obama was in the loop on the pursuit of
Michael Flynn and again I think that
there were people inside the
administration who were convinced that
Flynn did something of what she was
guilty and that he needed to be
pressured by the FBI that's why the
investigation stayed open the evidence
supports that theory of the case it does
that is not a conspiracy theory those
documents are public we now see them and
so the but the media are willing it is
it's pretty amazing and Caylee mcenany
who's doing a very good job as press
secretary by the way Caylee mcenany she
came out yesterday and she scolded the
media for their lack of curiosity in the
Flynn case and she's right to do so
you're an attorney and the president
spokesperson perhaps you could lay out
the elements of this crime what crime
was committed and in what way I assume
you're referring to the Obama
administration and the unmasking and
vomiting what is it what are the
elements of that crime yeah and I'm
really glad you asked because there
hasn't been a lot of journalists to
curiosity on this front and I'm very
glad that you asked this question look
there were a number of questions raised
by the actions of the Obama
administration and she is correct about
all of that Megan I don't think you
leave it to President Trump to lay out
the theory of the case here nor do I
think that anybody's gonna get
prosecuted nor should they be prosecute
only Susan Rice gets prosecuted front
masking I think that the person who
leads to the media should be prosecuted
but if you don't have evidence then you
should but again there was this general
miasmatic level of corruption inside the
obama administration where basically
obama would say wouldn't it be nice if
this happened and then somewhere down
the line it would happen right obama
didn't order the IRS to explicitly go
out there and censor 501c3 groups on the
basis of ideology it just happened after
he suggested publicly that it would be
nice if 501c3 groups weren't biased
toward the right it obama is a is a
smart political operator he wouldn't be
caught dead with his hand in the cookie
jar on this sort of stuff that is not to
suggest even malign motive maybe he
actually thought that trump was
colluding with russia maybe all these
people convince themselves that's what
was happening but that does not exempt
people from following the rules okay
time for a very very quick thing that i
like so things that i like today there's
a really interesting novel by an Israeli
novelist named yogi Brandis it's called
the orchard and it's all about the the
generation that they really created the
the Talmud or write private previous to
the creation of the Talmud it begin it's
really the story of Rabbi Akiva 's wife
and Rabbi Akiva Rabbi Akiva is one of
the most famous sages in Jewish history
it's revisionist so if you're an
Orthodox Jew it's got some stuff in that
it's gonna leave you scratching your
head and be like well I don't remember
this part from Islamic but with that
said the last twenty pages or so of this
book are quite moving and quite
excellent the book is called the orchard
by yogi Brandis and you're interested in
sort of ancient Jewish conflicts in
ancient Jewish philosophy the Christians
come into play a lot here because this
is around the birth time of Christianity
Paul Saul of Tarsus is a character in
the book now you can check it out the
orchard by Elfie Brandis is translated
from the Hebrew and the translation is
pretty good alrighty we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets audio is
mixed by micro Romina hair and makeup is
by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 25 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]